so in our last video about Deadpool I
asked you guys the question which
version of Deadpool should we do next
then by a very slim margin our winner
turned out to be Lady Deadpool so
without further ado I present our next
Deadpool character Lady Deadpool
so what we're going to do in this video
is we're going to go in the chronology
of Lady Deadpool at least what I believe
is a chronology of Lady Deadpool so
we're going to jump out of her I guess
kind of book appearances in terms of the
appearance chronology and we're going to
go with her character and so what we do
is we jump to 2010 with the revolution
will not be televised which is a single
one-shot solo story featuring what seems
to be the backstory of Lady Deadpool and
what we find out is that and this
alternate reality Lady Deadpool is more
of a hermit she simply hates being
around people she just lives inside of
her own home and she's more or less a
person who is in a lot of ways almost
exactly like the earth-616 Deadpool but
what happens is that while she's
spending time I guess with herself that
her cable goes out and so as a result
she's forced to go out and go outside of
her apartment into the general public
where she works revealed that she is up
having to deal with people but what we
also find out is there some kind of
massive I guess would be rebellion
taking place where people are taking to
the streets and all different kinds of
things and so we don't really know how
it was this set of events came to be all
we really know is that at some point
along the line a revolution broke out
between the federal government and the
American people and so what we do here
is we pick up with Lady Deadpool as
she's going about trying to figure out
what's going on and she comes across a
failed actor named Charles but Charles
the way he's given to us is an extremely
attractive person and so Lady Deadpool
immediately becomes smitten with him and
so she basically does everything she can
to impress him to basically garner his
attention but what Charles is doing here
is he's trying to step into the role of
being a revolutionary of being someone
that people can look up to to take a
stance against the government now while
all this is going on Lady Deadpool is
being watched by the future leaders of
the rebellion of the resistance army and
so the question is what are they going
to do with regards to attaining her
assistance and so what we learn is that
once they basically garner her
assistance we're not really told how
exactly it is that they manage to do
this but we find the she's basically the
bodyguard for Charles and so what she
does is follow Charles on his speaking
tours and the more she spends time with
him the more she starts to fall in love
with him but it's more of this really
weird kind of backwards version of love
it is to say every single thing he does
that happens to happen in her favor she
thinks is him coming
and saying that he loves her and so what
happens is that on one of his speaking
engagements that a man steps up and
begins screaming at Charles the reason
being because this man's wife and
children left him to join Charles
rebellion and so when he asked why it is
this had happened Charles simply makes a
statement of look at the man and then
look at Charles and the reason is
because that man's just not attractive
and so what happens here is a man gets
angry and throws his shoe at Charles and
then Lady Deadpool jumps in the way to
save Charles from the assault of this
shoe at which point she then turns her
gun on this unnamed man and shoots him
to death and so what happens here while
all this is taking place again is we
find the Captain America I guess general
America in this reality is siding with
the loyalists he's fighting on behalf of
the government and so what we learn is
that the current girlfriend of Charles a
I guess a redheaded woman that's simply
referred to as ginger by Lady Deadpool
but whose actual name is Sloan there's
apparently a sleeper agent for General
General America who is basically spying
on Charles and so what happens here is
it eventually comes to light what is
this going on and Kath I'm sorry general
America appears to Charles and says that
he's being taken away and he's being
taken back to to some sort of facility
that belongs to the government because
he's been branded as a traitor and so
what happens here is we jump back to
this facility and we find that a person
who apparently knew Charles in high
school is now the individual who's
leading this rebellion or leading this
this new army that fights on behalf of
the government and so as a result he
basically I guess more or less mocks
Charles here and he gives us the
backstory of saying that when Charles
was younger he was very unattractive he
had surgical work done to make himself
attractive but the fact remains that
he's sort of being goaded but again
while this is happening lady Deadpool
has apparently retreated back to her
apartment after having been defeated or
being stunned by a Sloan and so as a
result she's joined by the future
leaders of the rebel army where I guess
the now leaders of the rebel army and
they enlists her aid to fight on behalf
of the rebels against the federal
government but only if if Lady Deadpool
or I guess if they will show Lady
Deadpool where it is a Charles as being
being held at and so what happens is
Lady Deadpool and these rebel forces
head to the military base that's ran by
the federal government and as a result
she does her best to try to
Charles but in the process Charles its
presumably injured and most likely
killed and Lady Deadpool takes this time
to basically kiss Charles which again
there's really this kind of weird thing
now with that origin story with that
backstory out of the way now we jump to
the good stuff
the actual first appearance that Lady
Deadpool had is and Deadpool Merc with a
mouth issue number seven I believe and
Deadpool Merc with a mouth was a series
for Deadpool whereby he was trying to
return the zombified head of Deadpool
referred to his head pool back to the
zombie universe and what this did is it
gave us a series of dead pools but
pretty much all these dead pools were
killed off but in issue number seven he
encounters lady Deadpool
now when he encounters Lady Deadpool
she's already fighting on behalf of the
government and I'm sorry on behalf of
the rebel forces against the government
and so she's fighting general america
and so what happens here is that while
she's fighting general america that
general america seems to be at a point
whereby he's about to deal a killing
blow to lady Deadpool and then Deadpool
from earth-616 jumps in and he saves
lady Deadpool and so beta that basically
the two of them were able to defeat
general America here and as a result
lady dope or did Lady Deadpool says
there has to be something she can do to
repay Deadpool for his actions and so
the two of them kiss and almost
immediately after they kissed they
regret it because as far as they say
it's like kissing themselves it's really
sort of the screwed up thing and so what
Deadpool says he's going to take the
head of a head of head pool he's going
to take the head of the zombie Deadpool
and he's going to continue on his
mission - I get it back to the zombie
universe and that's that's where we end
that's where we stop with this version
of Lady Deadpool now from here we jump
to prelude to the Deadpool core issue
number one and this again is the final
part of this video with regards to Lady
Deadpool we find that Lady Deadpool is
continuing to a fight against the forces
of america on behalf of the rebels and
so what we find is that general america
is still alive but that his arm was been
has been removed and the reason why is
almost removed was because in Deadpool
Merc with a mouth
Deadpool had thrown the head of zombie
Deadpool at a general America in order
to defeat general America
and as a result he had to cut off the
arm of general america to keep the
zombie plague from spreading and so what
we do is we find that again as a lady
Deadpool is continuing to fight on
behalf of the rebels that she's able to
take down two helicopters and then her
and general america start fighting once
again and so as the two of them are
going at it we find the Deadpool from
earth-616 appears yet again and says
that the whole reason why he's here is
because he has to recruit Lady Deadpool
for the purpose of saving the multiverse
and so what happens is that general
america realizes that Deadpool has
returned and again all three of these
people start fighting one another again
and so what happens is that while while
general america is fighting deadpool
from earth-616 that lady deadpool stabs
general america through the leg and when
she stabs him to the leg it causes a
momentary enough distraction that
deadpool can knock him out using his
using his sword handle and so as a
result Lady Deadpool says that she'll
join Deadpool as they go about and try
to save the multiverse with that being
said that brings the end in our video
with regards to Lady Deadpool now my
personal opinion I think head pulls a
lot more interesting and so what we'll
do in the next video is we'll talk about
head pool and then from there we'll jump
into Deadpool kills Deadpool with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly
you